let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
welcome
is in indictment day hell I don't know
I'm a little late
[Music]
no I'm not saying I promise we're here
we are here on what is supposed to be
indictment day
and you know the thing is yesterday we
watched as Republicans we're reasonable
we're reasonable you should not protest
don't protest and the reason why they
said that it's obvious this morning No
One's Gonna protest no one's in support
of this fool no one and the only protest
we've seen that has sprung up
in New York City or protests against him
which there's not even that many people
there against him because most people
are like yeah he's a criminal so what
he's being charged for crimes that he
committed is that really a [__]
surprise should we be a surprise that
this criminal is being indicted no we
should not
we should not be indicted and the plot
lines is slipping through their fingers
folks
it's slipping through their fingers
they can't even imagine they can't even
manage to make Hunter Biden's laptop the
reason why Donald Trump's being indicted
that's that's how much the plot line is
slipping away from them
quick fast and in a hurry the problem is
the problem here is that he wants people
to commit violence to save him it's what
he wants you can say whatever the [__]
you want you can go on and on and on
about oh well it's a he said protest not
violence we know what he means
we know what he means he knows what
happens when he calls for peaceful Pro
patriotic protest he knows what happens
he knows
he watched it two years ago
problem is is all the people that would
commit violence for him
all the toothless spread neck
yolkaida the gravy seals they're all
charged
they're all charged or in prison or on
house arrest
who else is gonna do this for him who
who your Grammy and grandpappy who watch
Fox News
the the the [__] the professional
wrestling
groupies that show up at his cult
meetings his Nazi rallies really those
are the people you think are gonna go
around and commit violence in this
country they can't even rub two [__]
brain cells together
let alone figure out where to go protest
let alone violently what are they gonna
do bring their walkers with them
are they gonna come show up at the
protests with their walkers in their
wheelchairs with their oxygen tanks
this is all ridiculous folks
and and the Republicans and Maga are
losing the plot I mean it I've been
saying it for months now the plot is
slipping away from them
they can't decide if this is Hunter
Biden's laptop's fault Hillary Clinton's
fault Obama's fault Biden's fault maybe
it's a George Soros thing I mean they
keep saying that they're trying that out
oh man they're really they're really
working on the whole anti-semitic a Jew
did this thing
it's insanity
but it's not surprising
because they're desperate I mean even in
the house Judiciary Committee yesterday
Jim Jordan the the committee that has a
subcommittee about weaponization of
government literally threatened
yesterday if you prosecute Trump we will
come after you
the guy who claims that Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan
claims that the federal government was
weaponized against Donald Trump is going
to use the the federal government
weaponized against
Alvin Bragg who is an elected official
in New York in Manhattan as the district
attorney he's presenting his case before
a grand jury the grand jury will vote
rather the charge Trump or not based on
Alvin Bragg's case
this is really [__] dumb these
boneheads don't even know how our system
works they have no [__] clue they
don't want to know either and the reason
why is because it doesn't fit their
narrative it doesn't fit their plot line
it doesn't promote the fascism that they
want in this country and it's hilarious
you know we talk a lot about here that
the likeness
of this Republican real America First
Nazi party and the Nazi party of the
1930s and 1940s in Germany
there's one big difference folks there's
one big well a couple but the one big
difference is
Hitler didn't have us
Hitler did not have a pro-democracy
coalition that was marching against him
he did not have people who were well
informed
their government was in tatters
we are not in tatters
our Law and Order system
as much as it is a two-tier system they
keep saying that too
and they're just terrified terrified
that their tear is not going to protect
them anymore if it doesn't protect Trump
and their and their narrative and their
plotline is being smashed and they're
doing it
oh it's so beautiful
what a beautiful sight
all the while all the while ensuring
that Donald Trump is going to be the
nominee I don't know if you noticed this
yesterday
but Ron DeSantis came out and basically
sent shots over the bow calling Donald
Trump a cretan
in Sebastian gorka's words we're going
to talk about that later
[__]
Sebastian Gorka hates me and Gabe
Sanchez oh my God we got in his crawl he
is pissed off at us so we're going to
talk about that later
but Ronda santis throws a passive
aggressive uh oh man I don't know
anything about having sex with porn
stars and then paying them hush money so
that I can't get elected wink but he
sure does that piece of [__] that's
where Ron DeSantis tried yesterday
and Trump went
um you're a pedophile
oh my God you can't get better than this
folks
they're going to implode I know I know
they keep saying oh this is gonna
guarantee that he becomes the president
of the United States and in the same
breath they say it's going to destroy
our country so which is it
or is it the same thing he's going to be
president and that may destroy our
country I mean maybe they may be on to
something here maybe we should listen
but there is one thing for sure that
these people do not understand and I'm
talking about any commentator out there
some do most don't they do not
understand what what election cycle we
are in
they do not understand what election is
in front of us they have no [__] clue
they act like they know our government
and our system and they oh yeah well we
know you don't know you're a dummy
we are in a Republican primary cycle
right now there will be no challenge to
the Democratic nominee trust me just lay
that aside I've talked about this
nauseam we don't even have to approach
it again
we right now the the political cycle the
election cycle we are in
is a Republican primary and the best
part is is they're feeding the
Republicans are feeding you are feeding
you the way to beat them on a platter
because they keep saying this is
political
well let's make them make it into
politics
let's Force this wedge everyone keeps
saying oh this is bad for Democrats
because this is the weakest case they
got against Trump how the [__] do you
know that
you don't know that
you have no clue what evidence Michael
Cohen had that wasn't given an open
court in a federal case you don't know
the case was not made against individual
one because Michael Cohen took a federal
plea deal
you don't know the evidence
you don't know the charges you don't
even know what crime has been committed
since the hush money payment
since the deal that was made with
Michael Cohen since Michael Cohen
apparently was seeking pardons according
to Trump and this Costello
which yesterday
Trump team Trump made a a grave error in
this case if these charges are real and
there's evidence to back them up they
made a great mistake
they gave their entire defense in a
trial to Alvin Bragg the entire thing
it's been all over and well legal
analyst Glenn kirsner another Federal uh
former Federal prosecutors that said
look this is a [__] gift
because the grand jury didn't take very
long and they only wanted to see six of
the six million emails that Costello had
to offer
that's the report
and they didn't call back Michael Cohen
yet which means Bragg does not need
Michael Cohen to rebut meaning
the testimony that Costello gave didn't
help Trump's case it hurt Trump's case
why do you think Bragg and the Manhattan
D.A invited Trump and his team to come
in and offer rebuttal so they could see
what their play was at trial they're
he's [__] here folks I know everyone's
like ah this is the weakest case it may
be the weakest case I don't know my
guess is though in the Manhattan DA's
office with Alvin Bragg with him not
wanting to prosecute before and new
evidence coming to light possibly new
crimes who knows
I mean this we know Donald Trump loves
to obstruct and we know he loves witness
tampering we learned that from the
January 6th select committees when he
was trying to witness tamper with Cassie
hutchendon Hutchinson
this is that news this is not new stuff
and then the claim that somehow somehow
it's political what the [__] of course
it's political he made a [__] hush
money payment and covered it up with
fraud or whatever
so he could [__] not have that out
into the public during a political
campaign yeah it was political on his
part
what crime has he committed in the last
[__] five years six years that hasn't
been political
you're telling me that the [__] the
racketeering that he may be charged with
it looks like the Georgia
D.A down there Fannie Willis is going to
look into racketeering charges you're
telling me that that is that's not
political he was trying to overthrow our
vote George's vote our government that's
not political you're telling me the
January 6th Insurrection where he tried
to get his [__] spread next to go to
the Capitol yalkaida
the gravy seals to go overthrow our
government and kill government officials
in his name so he could be dictator
you're telling me that's not political
get the [__] out of here with this
political [__] it's all political every
[__] bit of it
all of it up and down and I'm tired of
liberals not being able to say that it
is political he made it [__] politics
the 17 counts of fraud that the Trump
organization were convicted on
in in a New York Court that sent Alan
weitzelberg to Rikers that's not
political that was all business [__]
but these other cases he stole our
[__] documents from the government so
he could cover up his crimes while he
was there that's not political the [__]
out of here with this [__] of course
it's political he made it political
why do you think he's being investigated
this is all nonsense
lean into it don't walk away from it
don't try to scare away from their from
their stupid narrative that this is
politics why are you scared of Paul why
in the [__] is the left scared of
politics we should not be scared
we should be loud we should get [__]
loud and pissed that's what we should
get
you goddamn right it's politics you God
damn right it is
you know you know that I'm I'm gonna
stake my foot in the sand in any
narrative I can and and that's the other
thing that's crazy is the right wing is
like oh my God this is all politics and
look the left's just trying to frame up
a narrative
finally [__] finally [__] finally
what do you think politics is what do
you think elections are
do you think we win elections because we
have good ideas you are a [__]
bonehead if you think Americans are
paying attention to line items and bills
you're a dumb son of a [__] you are J
you are just way out of your depth in
politics if you think that the majority
of Americans are paying attention to
line items and bills and how it affects
them
Jesus Christ we we talked yesterday with
just Jessica Piper here about this very
issue that rural people vote against
their what we see as interest because of
affiliation alone
because my daddy voted Republican and my
granddaddy voted Republican
what in the [__] do you think Trump has
in common with these people
what
other than he's a white piece of trash
huh
when I was growing up where I grew up in
a rural area those people in that area
would have hated that [__] some
[__] Silver Spoon elitist
who who who ganders around with [__]
porn stars and pays him much money
payments
who colludes with a [__] with the
[__] USSR
are you kidding me
are you [__] kidding me
why do you think they've why do you
think they are where they are they are
where they are because of their
messaging and their narrative
and it's time for us to form a bunch of
them [__] them even if they contradict
each other I don't give a [__]
they run around lying they run they run
around talking all kinds of crazy ass
[__]
mounting all kinds of platitudes that
don't even make sense
and the reason why they do it you wanna
you wanna know the reason why they do it
people listen
it doesn't have to make sense
stop with your data stop with your
[__] stupid poles people don't give a
[__]
they don't care who's the president they
don't care who who is on the Supreme
Court they don't give a [__] who their
Senator is they don't care who their
congressman is I know it feels good for
you to think that every single American
cares about this [__] and it would make
me feel a lot better if that was the
truth but it's not it's a [__] lie
it's a [__] lie and I'm not gonna sit
here and lie to you I'm just not gonna
do it and the truth of the matter is
that most of Americans don't give a good
God damn
about politics or the government they
just don't give a [__]
they care more about who's gonna pitch
tomorrow or who's throwing the football
on Sunday
or who got traded to their team or who's
the new coach of their team
foreign
it's time we play into that it's time we
use our microphones and it's time we use
our voices to tap into the American
public and message to them the way the
right has for years
and got them to this deluded [__]
point
we can save our democracy with our
voices it is possible
not only can we save it we can progress
it we can make it better
but we have we have to stay together and
we have to get [__] loud
do not back down do not back down when
they make a stupid [__] argument
throw the argument in their face I don't
even care if you believe the [__]
rebuttal [__] it
it's time we win
because it doesn't matter what Alan
Bragg does it doesn't matter what Jack
Smith does it doesn't [__] matter
what Fannie Willis does or who charges
who or who indicts him
it is us who are the jury
it is us who are the prosecutor
It Is Us
who tells him no [__] you don't get to
be president [__]
we have a trial in front of us folks
there is a trial to come
and it is the 2024 election
and Donald Trump is going to put it in
full [__] swing for the Republican
primary they did it yesterday with him
and Ron DeSantis
get excited about indictments get pissed
off that indictments aren't happening
yelling scream when the right [__]
lies about what is going on then the
evidence that's being presented
but remember this
remember
there's only one thing that matters to
our democracy Now
only one
and that is to fight this election and
to get our messaging and our narrative
in a position where we can beat these
fascists
they're Nazis I know people oh my God
how outrageous you are so outrageous
calling them Nazis really am I that
outrageous
am I
they're trying to legislate your fellow
countrymen out of existence
they're taking away parental consent
they're taking away your rule schools
they're taking away your Liberty
and your bodily autonomy they don't want
you to have any other religion or no
religion
other than theirs
Jesus Christ they're on State House
floors using the Bible as their reason
to pass legislation
it's no joke
they're banning books
because of Lies
the right wing has demaga cult and a
fervor
the good news is and I'm here to report
and I would not lie to you
that is a small percentage of the
country yeah there's a lot of them
there's a lot of delusional [__] out
there our education system has been [__]
for a long time
it's designed that way by Republicans
but there are more of us than there are
of them
Joe Biden
Joe Biden didn't get 81 million votes
okay I'll admit it Joe Biden did not get
81 million votes
a hefty amount of those votes were
against Trump
and against trumpism remember that
remember even though Americans don't
give a [__] about politics they don't
give a [__] about who the president is
or who it isn't
on a daily it doesn't affect their daily
lives the way they see it it's not true
but that's just the way they feel
in the end
they made the decision that he should
not be in charge of our nation and our
sacred democracy
and the process in which we can use our
democracy to Grant Liberty equality and
Equity to all people that are here I
don't give a [__] of your citizen or not
so stay strong
stay confident liberalism is not weak
oh that's the hilarious part about it
all that's the thing that is really
really really catching them in the ass
it really is
it's coming back it's the they're the
dog who caught the car here
when they thought liberalism was weak
when they thought liberal democracy was
weak
when they think that Justice
is weak
it's not
it's real it's here
and we must stand and yell and scream
and pump our message and pump our
narrative and we will win again [__]
those indictments I mean we're gonna use
them as messaging
you goddamn right we're gonna frame
every single indictment we can for our
our narrative
to beat the absolute pants off Grandpa
we're gonna do it and we're gonna do it
together so make sure you're here every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific while
you're here on YouTube right now hit the
Subscribe button you must watch this
show every single weekday for two full
hours the Tony Michaels podcast also
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod download every single episode even
if you watch download on Apple Spotify
Google it's free go to Facebook if
you're on Facebook right now follow me
at the Tony Michaels you're not going to
want to miss an episode also you can go
to the upwire.com And subscribe to the
up wires YouTube channel where we also
simulcast guess what we're on Twitch too
this [__] is free two hours a day every
single day for you to get your National
narrative and your National messaging
from the source
The Source yes
I have been known as the rushland ball
of the left and it does not bother me at
all this is pro-democracy propaganda
right here on the Tony Michaels podcast
and we will win in 2024 we will beat
back these people because guess what
they're a bunch of Nazis but they're
nincompoop Nazis and today is Tuesday
it's Taco Tuesday it's Texas Paul
Tuesday hell it might even be indictment
Tuesday everyone stick around we got
Texas Paul when we come right back right
after these messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product part in blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard in blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your part in blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
oh baby there were there were like
the hand pins not even
I don't even know if you could call it a
dozen
I mean there's like
a half a dozen maybe and maybe a half a
dozen is a stretch
I don't know maybe half a dozen is a
stretch uh to say what kind of protest
is happening there in New York City of
course they're setting up barriers uh in
New York City I have been since
yesterday looks like they're setting up
barriers around the United States
capital
oh boy he called for protest right he's
like ah protest protest protest get out
and save me hurry I'm gonna be indicted
he's terrified
and then and then when they figured out
hey No One's Gonna show up at these
[__] protests they got out yesterday
like oh don't protest we're calling on
you not to protest
we just we just don't we just don't want
to um
once we you to protest and the reason
why they did that Texas Paul the reason
why they did this is because they know
that no one was going to show up they
know no one's gonna show up so they're
like we got to make sure we gotta make
sure
that that everyone believes that we told
them not to come that's why they didn't
come this is [__] it's what a wild
timeline we live in
yeah as soon as everybody started
reporting that nobody showed up they you
know they immediately came out with that
[__] story well this is by Design
like they told political right right
well hey that's a nice hat you got on
there and thanks man I appreciate it it
just showed up in the mail about two
days ago oh good good good that's it
that's a nice that was a lot of posters
brother that was a lot of postage yeah
well you know I figured I'd send you one
you know you you deserve one you're on
the show uh so often so I figured you'd
you'd need a [__] em hat or a couple of
them I sent you two of them didn't I
yeah you did well that's looking you got
get the blue in there and then I got a
nice looking gray one you like that you
like the flex fit you like the fitted
half I do that is badass man that is
nice this is actually literally the
nicest hat I own man it really is God
damn right that's why I like the flex
fit I mean it may not be the best
looking hat but it is a comfortable hand
don't uh that's a good looking hat well
of course I make it look pretty but well
you know you know happens it happens uh
so I I haven't been able to talk to you
um since the news broke on Saturday well
now I knew that this was coming right
because we watched his rants we watched
him rant on on Thursday and Friday his
diapers were obviously full he'd been
[__] himself for days and then on
Saturday he finally let the cat out of
the bag that they're gonna indict him
and arrest him now my guess is is his
his attorneys finally said hey
Costello's gonna go in on Monday he's
going to [__] fail because they we
just don't have the evidence to stop
this we're gonna try because he was
begging them to stop this I I would
imagine that's what's happening and
Costello goes in on Monday but but miss
Mr q and on her see the thing is if he
fails they're going to indict you on
Tuesday which it actually doesn't look
like we're going to have an indictment
because they're really preparing or
we're preparing because he said Tuesday
I think they switched it to tomorrow
because they were like well what's just
[__] we'll just go to one more day and
if if his supporters do show up they'll
be [__] confused right like I mean as
if they're not already confused but
maybe I'm wrong with the logistics on
that but it doesn't look like we're
actually going to see any news until
tomorrow that's what I'm gathering
yeah CBS is coming out with something
this morning saying that they've got got
some inside line on it or whatever but
I'd you know I'll be honest with you
Tony I just when when Trump was the only
source that this was going to happen
Tuesday I completely wrote it off I
really did I can't believe the [__]
thing he says really exactly exactly I
immediately all of my followers on all
my social media I said look Trump is the
only source on this [__] happening
Tuesday don't plan your day on it don't
need I mean this guy's never been
reliable before he's not going to be
real he's a habitual liar you know his
his attorneys told him you're indicted
do you have of that Texas Paul that he
that he's a it's like you it's like you
have evidence of this or something oh my
God yeah it's like they only they only
cataloged what something like what is it
30 something thousand right provable
lies that he told during his
administration right well and I I mean
you know if if you're not aware that
this guy's a [__] liar then you have
your head you know Waist Deep up your
ass I mean this is not this is not news
and and I love I love because I was in a
Twitter space yesterday uh with Gabe
Sanchez again with Sebastian Gorka and
let's see Rudy Giuliani was in there
um so we were we were knocking on Rudy
knocking on Sebastian Gorka and um the
great the craziest part about some of
the narrative from the right is that
they keep talking about this as a hush
money payment which that's not actually
the thing that even even the federal
prosecutors were like well that's not
really the illegal thing right it was
the idea it was the idea that Michael
Cohen himself right out of his own
volition said Stormy Daniels may have
had an affair with Donald Trump
and because of that she may say
something so what I'm going to do is I'm
gonna go take a mortgage out and pay her
130 000 and to make sure that she
doesn't say anything with Donald Trump
not knowing a single thing ever about
this the problem is is Michael Cohen has
hates he has recordings of this the
other thing too that we don't know
because Donald Trump was individual one
in the federal case this is the other
crazy thing that manga gets [__]
twisted around they they yesterday there
was a guy that went on and on and on in
this space Texas ball he kept saying
what Michael Cohen is doing this to
reduce his sentence dude he's already
been sentenced in federal court the feds
made the case against him and really
honestly Alvin Bragg wouldn't even try
to make the case against Michael Cohen
because he's already served a [__]
Federal sentence for that charge so this
idea that Michael Cohen is now doing
this to to lessen his sentence dude he's
already served it's done it's over with
and besides the other the other thing
that gets me is they keep talking about
the statue of limitations and you can
you can um you've got plenty of evidence
of this I know just in the media that
Donald Trump did not stop criming at
during the hush payment or covering it
up or the payment that he made to
Michael Cohen when he was president of
the United States this is all nonsense
he witnessed he was witness tampering
during the [__] uh January 6 uh
hearings he's been obstructing justice
with the documents he's been obstructing
justice since he was [__] born so the
idea that he hasn't he stopped criming
on this issue when the hush money
payment it was given and then when he
covered it up by having Alan weisselberg
write it off his taxes or whatever the
hell they did this is all [__] and
you don't know just wait the evidence is
coming and I actually believe because
people keep saying this [__] too which
you don't know this they're saying that
this is the weakest case how do you know
you don't know what the grand jury is
seeing you don't know what Michael Cohen
had that didn't get presented in federal
court and open court because he took a
deal that was the [__] plan was for
Michael Cohen to take a deal so that
evidence didn't come to light
I didn't mean to get too off a track
there but go ahead no no you're no yeah
I'm amen you're you're nailing it a
couple things to point out is one this
guy Costello Bob Costello uh it's
I this is why I hate corporate media
Tony this is why I hate corporate media
and I beg people to please come
here come to our coalition to get
information because the corporate media
seems to have completely forgotten that
Bob Costello was Trump's lawyer he's in
the Mueller report his name's redacted
but it's it's him they're referring to
Bob Costello's giuliani's lawyer
during the impeachment trial when they
were talking about giuliani's dealings
in Ukraine Bob Costello was was
giuliani's lawyer Bob Costello was also
Steve bannon's lawyer when he refused to
show up for the Supreme Congressional
subpoena this guy is nothing but a trump
shill
and the mainstream media is talking
about him like it well this is this is
uh Cohen's former legal advisor
well [__] Cohen refused to retain
him
you know Cohen got into real legal
Jeopardy and he said I'm not going down
this going through this trial with
Trump's [__] attorney right you know
they you know well I mean I mean Cassie
Hutchison was the same way during the
January 6 elect committee I mean uh
there was a trump appointed Trump
appointed meaning they were paying for
her attorney the attorney that Trump
wanted and then she said no I'm done
with that I'm getting a real attorney
who's going to defend me and defend my
interest not his and that's why she
ended up going and testifying to what
she testified to and we we we saw an
open [__] committee and an open
hearing that that someone was witness
tampering with somebody someone was
obstructing so to to say that there was
no crimes committed after the hush money
payment was given and these guys Trump
and Cohen colluded is [__] ridiculous
that that's not possible for any crime
to happen after that they listen they've
been investigating this for [__]
years and I will remind people that it
is the same prosecutor the Manhattan
DA's office the same prosecutor who who
indicted and who who got convictions on
17 felony fraud charges on his business
and when I said that yesterday in this
Twitter space where uh Sebastian Gorka
was at a [__] [__] box
um where he was in there's some some I
don't know who it was but they were like
oh some kid just talked about the 17
counts but that wasn't him personally
that was his business like what the [__]
what are you talking about man yeah of
course it was Trump org but what you're
saying is Trump is never Trump has never
bragged about his business being him and
how smart he was and the only reason why
his business existed was because of him
it had a [__] name on it everywhere
give me a break you are grasping at
straws manga you are losing the plot
line I can tell you're desperate and in
your desperation only shows when you
talk about Bill Clinton and Paula Jones
that is hilarious do you know do you
know the details of the Paula Jones Bill
Clinton thing I mean come on you were
around I do I do let's talk about that
because that's one point they're gonna
make to you people uh in comments and in
Threads and it just it's [__]
laughable at best it's laughable go
ahead and let's talk about the Apollo
Jones difference of why why Apollo Jones
850 000 is different than the 130 000
that Michael Cohen paid Stormy Daniels
and then Donald Trump paid Michael Cohen
and falsely said it was legal fees let's
talk about it right it's really the the
the the basis I mean it's super simple
the Apollo Jones payment was a
court-ordered settlement after a Civil
Trial
the clintons weren't trying to pay her
anything this was not hush money this
was a civil settlement I'm saying you're
saying the clintons didn't approach
Paula Jones outside of the court system
or is that what you're saying are you
saying that these aren't even close to
being the same is that what you're
saying yeah actually if you want to draw
a comparison draw a comparison between
John Edwards yeah and Trump what were
the Republicans saying back when John
Edwards was caught felony charges in a
federal in a federal district what were
they saying about John Edwards at the
time when uh one of his donors paid his
mistress money after she had had a a
love child as it was called at the time
of John Edwards and uh John Edwards
ended up in court over campaign Finance
issues what what what what were the
Republicans saying back then were they
like oh it's all political they
shouldn't try John Edwards because it's
just political what were they saying
that he was a criminal that should be in
jail
are you kidding me
yeah
[__] out of John Edwards
He's going to be the new nominee I
believe I believe he
was president almost like it's almost
like we were like you know what we love
criminals let's make him the head of our
party it's almost like we did that it
feels like maybe no we didn't do that
okay no we didn't do it maybe I'm maybe
I'm remembering a delusional history
that manga is trying to remember because
it didn't happen this idea that this is
political and that's the other thing too
I want to mention and I want us to talk
about that I didn't mean to cut you off
but I want to talk about that yeah is
they keep saying it's political and my
my argument is we should lean into that
like I did in the first 30 minutes we
should lean into that of course it's
political it was about a campaign it was
about him paying hush money and then
you're legally committing fraud to
report it committing fraud to report it
so his so the American people didn't
know because he was running uh what is
it called a political campaign
all the crimes that this guy's committed
in the last six years has to do with
politics am I out of my mind that this
that somehow it's bad that this is about
politics he's made this about politics
right am I wrong
yeah absolutely absolutely they wanted
to be political because if it stays
political then their base stays with him
because the minute anything becomes
political reason goes out the window
when it goes to teams but yeah and
somebody just pointed out in in the
comments it's I'm glad they did that
John Edwards was acquitted
but we decried as Democrats decried that
that acquittal you know that we we did
not agree with that acquittal he was
acquitted because he was so damn crazy
that he didn't hide any of it he she was
his Trail photographer
she was literally on the campaign trail
with him as one of the most visible
people taking all the photographs you
see of John Edwards
she's taken the pictures
she's literally the person standing in
front of him taking the pictures
you know he was not paying her hush
money to make her go away he was asking
his donors to support her because that's
my gal
right Stormy Daniels Michael Cohen was
paying on Trump's behalf to keep her
quiet so his campaign did not get
damaged that is a campaign expenditure
period he committed the crime Alvin
Bragg only has to hold up the books and
say see
not here
payment's not here
right and the case is over that's why
Costello's testimony was such [__]
wow did you see him say you're so mad
they didn't call back in Michael Cohen
and I don't believe they're calling him
back in today I guess he's he's standing
by in case they do for rebuttal but I
don't think the grand jury's meeting
today because Trump tweeted or posted
what he posted Gabe Sanchez I want to I
want to follow on this point
um and here's here's why is because we
were in a space the other day not the
one yesterday but the one the other day
I believe on Saturday there's a
presidential um candidate what the guy
what the hell is that guy's name he's
acting like he's running against Trump
the the three pudding figures no no no
no no not not putting meatball the other
guy that was in the space and he was
talking about oh he was talking about
John Fury the Vic that's it this [__]
idiot he's always in his he's always in
a car going to a campaign event right
well and here's the thing here's what I
believe and this is a conspiracy theory
and his Uber Eats is what he's doing and
I I don't I don't give a [__] if people
think this is a conspiracy theory or not
uh my guess is he is he is actually uh
funded by Trump donors so that way it
looks like Trump has an opponent in this
race so that he can box out any other
opponents that's my guess because he was
very sympathetic in the space to Trump
but the funniest part is is Vivek
brought up this [__] bonehead and
you're not gonna know he is because you
don't watch right wing media he's been
all over right-wing media oan Newsmax
[__] Fox News he's in these [__]
right-wing spaces it's [__] crazy but
this guy was talking about
Texas ball he was talking about John
Kerry and he made some sort of [__]
some sort of uh uh you know hypothetical
that if John Kerry would have done this
John Kerry would have done that then
what would the left done and right done
and then someone asked him the follow-up
because here's why I think that this guy
is funded by Trump donors is because the
[__] didn't even know that John
Kerry's running mate John Edwards caught
a federal case for campaign Finance he
didn't even know it and when the
follow-up question asked he was
blindsided and that is the [__] point
listen folks I want to tell you the
audience out there these Republicans
these manga these real America First
Nazis they have no [__] clue what
they're talking about take advantage of
it they are I mean Gabe talk about the
space we were in yesterday these these
[__] boneheads were saying some crazy
ass I mean it's [__] wild the [__]
that they think that this is and isn't
it it was pretty so uh so I got on the
space and I was talking and by the way
by the way I'm I'm going to be invited
to this space did they invite you they
invited me yeah yeah and I think I might
go in a little bit this afternoon so if
anyone out there listening watch my
Twitter account yeah and and watch games
uh we might go in this space and I'm
telling you it's hard to listen to I had
to shut it off last night uh when Leb
Parnes came on and you're gonna talk
about that I know but I had to shut it
off because I couldn't [__] take it
anymore but you have to go listen for at
least five or ten minutes and listen to
how much the plot is slipping away from
them right so basically the kind of a
quick summary so I get into the space
yesterday and you know Tony and I are
always texting during the day and I was
like oh there's another space and he was
like I'll go check it out so he's
listening while I'm talking and other
people are talking
the craziest things are being said
there's one guy in there there's like
one guy Jim who is the ultimate
mansplainer uh trying to be like do you
know what uh article one or like you
know the first the the First Amendment
article one
clause three and he goes off
the attempt to be like oh I know exactly
what it means so this is how we should
interpret it and what's being done to
Trump is a is is provocation for
fear-mongering and provocation for them
to push this idea that right Wingers are
trouble and they're going to cause
damage
and then this other guy goes in he says
uh you know all you uh leftists and
Democrats you you want riots and I was
like hold on hold on hold on I just want
to just like quickly come out here and
say we don't want violence no one from
the left is pushing for riots no one
from the left is pushing for people to
actually be fighting and causing
violence outside of these different
areas that you're that you're protesting
if your maganation as you just called it
wants to get up and fight and get in
trouble that's on you guys but no one on
the left is actively saying oh man I
hope they do this if you guys do it
we're just gonna sit by and say [__]
around and find out you guys talk about
you're the rule of law and order then
you better [__] sit by and and
understand that there are consequences
to you saying that you want violence
there's always this projection then you
then then at one point we had Rudy
Giuliani who came into this Rudy was in
there real the real Rudy the real the
real Rudy Johnny came into space no one
only only the host was able to ask a
question he came in for like 10 15
minutes and then he bounced right there
was follow-up questions of like what do
you think about Rudy Giuliani and I was
like well we could talk a lot of things
I don't really like him uh and what I
went on to say was like this guy you
should have said you should have said
[__] Rudy is what right I mean well you
know I try to be I'm a little less
diplomatic in the space than Gabe
Sanchez is Right a little more
diplomatic but in in this space you know
you've got all these crazy things being
said and people like oh you know Rudy
Giuliani by the way if you go through he
talks about how uh what's being done
right now by Alvin Bragg and the
Democrats is a fascist state right these
fascists are trying to control the
country which I was like was he the only
one that said fascist because I think he
was the only one who knows
yeah Seb Gorka [__] hates me every
time I talk every time you or me talk
because I think he knows where I think
he knows we're affiliated with minus
touch probably I think that's what it is
he looked us up because he blocked me in
that [__] [__] yeah that's right Seb
if you're out there you're a [__]
[__] man yeah um he he blocked me and
Gabe and I I think well he blocked you a
while ago he blocked me last year and
the funny thing about this is on
Saturday when I spoke about how Trump
loves to [__] and moan on his truth
social which they got very triggered by
they're like well what do you expect
they banned it from all these places and
I was like that's the right to [__] and
moan and I was like [__] yeah you
creaked I think that's what said so Seb
Gorka gets all up in his Fields when I
say [__] and moan and he's like oh yes
he has the right to say [__] and man
arm said Goku you Creighton
and so uh if you ever listen to Seb
Gorka his go-to uh insult is to call
everyone Creighton Creighton
and it's just it's sad because you know
that they have no argument yeah it's all
projection though from him
the biggest question that I and Joe
Walsh who is a republican Joel came in
for a while yeah Joe came in so Joe and
I were asking we're like look it's one
simple question
did Trump lie about the 2020 election
and then Seb Gorka was like oh well why
don't we talk about this other thing and
he would not look and so when you ask
actual actual just real questions like
let's not refute the facts because
that's what they're in the court of law
Rudy Giuliani lied he didn't have
evidence he had theories he was kicked
out by judges especially Trump judges
the DC bar
uh found him in violation of his
attorney uh his role as an attorney
during the 2020 for trying to push this
big lie these are actual facts but
anytime you present them they go oh no
that's the Deep State you've created
even when even when we brought up uh
even when we brought up the fox Files
about how these Fox correspondents are
in text on on email all of these
different written correspondence showing
how they didn't actually believe it but
they had to push it and some people
they're like oh I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna believe that I'm not gonna look at
that I'm not going to read those things
and it's like well yeah of course
because you guys are in this isolated
vacuum this Silo and you're unwilling to
accept the fact that the people that you
were listening to on Fox News
we're [__] playing you the whole time
for Ratings but you won't accept a fact
even though it's in literally in these
depositions it's in these court
documents that show you that they knew
what they were doing and they were
working in bad practice and in bad faith
so you you right now people on these on
these calls on these spaces are
unwilling to accept the fact that
they're wrong right and so anytime you
go after someone on the right anytime
someone does something illegal and you
say hey they should be held a combo and
you look on the left or the right if you
do something bad you should be held
accountable whether Hunter Biden or or
Donald Trump whoever you are you should
be held accountable to things that
you've done well I'm glad you I'm glad
you you brought that up because I put
out a good meme on my Twitter so go
check it out about Bill Clinton and
Jeffrey Epstein it's a great one yeah
it's a great one Texas Paul um I I gotta
say though yesterday it was funny and
there's a lot of clips of the
non-protest protest and this is why they
they came Kevin McCarthy and all these
people because Rudy Giuliani said it in
the space too I don't think people
should protest I know you had the right
but you shouldn't protest and the reason
why is because they realized no one was
actually going to show up here's an
actual scene this is rsbn this is a
Trader TV News Network that is in New
York City this is large margins uh yeah
in this or right in this her uh her
homie as they would call it maybe
um what's funny is I can't tell if he
knows who he's talking to
um obviously this is uh one of the
halves of the good liars here
um and they actually put out this video
I mean they clipped our sbn's live
coverage of him talking but listen
listen to the uh do the banter here back
and forth Texas ball and tell us what
you think so I mean what's your take on
this so far there's a lot of people out
here yeah it seems like there's a lot of
media
um I would say just just basically all
media and I guess there's uh is it
Braxton Braxton and then I see another
guy with the flat it seems like there's
about 10 Trump supporters here but
mostly their media oh my God Texas ball
this is we knew this was gonna happen
though we knew when he was calling to
protest protest protest I knew No One's
Gonna show up where the hell are they
gonna go where are they gonna go to
protest and save him where
yeah and you know man I I just I laughed
so freaking hard at that I went to a
fundraiser last weekend and spoke at a
fundraiser I was a headliner at a
fundraiser first time in my life I've
ever been the headliner of anything
250 people showed up
and I'm not a former president you know
what I'm saying I mean if you can't get
more than I mean I think
I think not at like 16 people showed up
to protest for Donald Trump man I mean
it's not even 16 not even tens of people
that's it and you have to get to 20 to
be tens you got to get to 24 to be
dozens and they couldn't even make it to
tens of people wow I mean it was
hilarious I do have to take one issue
with something Gabe said though yeah go
ahead he said nobody's calling for
violence and that's not exactly true
that's not exactly true the local New
Yorkers I don't know if you're well
following it blew up Twitter yesterday
because the proud boy said that well
they're gonna have to go defend their
cult leader and the local New Yorkers
said you show up here we will beat your
ass
it was just playing every day it wasn't
an organization it was just plain
Everyday People we will beat your ass
and then they started linking that story
where the the couple of The Proud boys
showed up at a drag show and got the
[__] Adam foreign I haven't been able to
play that video maybe I should but
here's here's an actual protest I want
to show this first here's an actual
protest this is from this morning
um and this is this is the protest um
that is happening that is an actual
protest and it's pretty small still
because I I don't think a lot of people
really give a [__] about this but watch
this tape here interestingly enough we
bring you this live shot here we know
the the former president has called for
for protests in a peaceful manner uh
many Republicans push back on that but
interestingly enough it's the opposite
side that's outside protesting now
saying Insurrection Tick Tock time's up
the possible indictment of former
president Trump there
um again what signs really look like
they were made by the Grassroots Grace
Roots groups too don't they Sean
oh he really he really got him there he
really got those broken you know you can
go to your local King goes right you can
also order a three by ten Banner with
whatever you want you know what's funny
you know it's funny you could have these
banners made three four five years ago
and they would still be relevant today
so it's not like it's not like they had
to order these last [__] minutes give
me a [__] break now to give you
context to give you context that is a
Newsmax report and they are sending
cameras the media is sending cameras to
have some sort of sensation done and
that's the thing that I keep saying and
I kept saying in the space you people
are [__] boneheads you do not I told
them uh Saturday here's what I told them
in the space on Saturday that space we
were in I said look because Tom Fenton
was in there on Saturday he won't go in
there now because he scared will the
gate will go in he he okay he came in
yesterday and he was like uh it was okay
yeah said he was on his radio show yeah
he was like uh I just want to make sure
that this uh William Leggett is in and
here this William which is William
legate right I always I always feel like
Seb wears a monocle probably because
like that's how I feel but he's like I
just want to make sure that uh this will
Leggett isn't here for the way that he
disrespected Tom fitchen Tom fitchen is
a patriot and there's no way that we can
allow this will Leggett back in here so
here's what happened so here's what
happened on Saturday uh Tom Fenton will
will comes up on stage and I think he
says something and then Tom chimes in
and calls him a Marxist and and then or
no no he calls him a Marxist will was in
the space but they wouldn't allow will
to come up and respond to him right and
I think he also might have blocked him
too so he couldn't send him so he
couldn't send him a DM so what so what
will did was will send him a text
message and in the space live in the
space and I think it's still recording
you can go listen to this in the 10
hours that was if you can find it but
we'll text Tom Fenton on his personal
cell phone and said who are you calling
a Marxist and then uh Benton responded
uh who is this he said this is legate
and [__] the guy you called the Marxist
right the guy you call the Marxist and
Tom Fenton got terrified in the space
he's like how could you let this happen
I what kind of tools are you using oh my
God it's see see these people are after
us and Will's like I just text you why'd
you call me a Marxist yeah you did you
called me what happened and then and
then of course everyone because nobody
understands what doxing actually is
they're like oh they're doxing him
they're dogs they don't know what
indictment is yeah
why would you think they would know what
dancing is I know and then they were
like Tom was like oh he's he's doxing me
he's going to reveal my private
information that's totally unethical and
Will's like dude you called me a Marxist
I'm a business owner okay I own my own
business it's a capitalist you know
what's funny you know what's funny about
that is um for people who don't know
will will will actually is the co-owner
of um pillow fight company but are an
owner over there but more than more
importantly Will's been a business owner
since he was like 14 years old yes a
very successful business owner and the
other thing too that people don't know
about will is that will is tied to Peter
Thiel he he and early on when he was
younger years and years ago he he had a
uh
so it was a scholar or something yeah so
there's a program back I don't know if
Peter Thiel doesn't anymore but Peter
Thiel had a thing called the teal
fellows and he was I think one of the
first couple classes in there this is
when I was in San well Tom Fenn wouldn't
know that right and by the way Tom Finn
doesn't know what a Marxist is if he
calls will again to Marxist yeah what a
[__] idiot just because will again
fights for Liberty on Twitter and
doesn't put up with manga's [__]
makes him a Marxist get the [__] out of
here he wasn't posting he wasn't posting
the phone number anywhere he wasn't
sharing no it just it's just he had the
phone number and he texted again from
and here's the thing and he he even went
in after because they're like whoa
what's going John you know and he had to
like explain the situation he's like I
didn't docs him I texted him also
I think he might have said in the space
or might have been in a a tweet but he
was like I got the number from somebody
that is friends with uh Tom Finn they
say a lot of wait wait wait wait will
said Tom Fenton has friends he said well
come on
that is true I thought you were saying
that Tom Finn had friends I don't know
about that I say friends that's that's a
far stretch I mean calling Willa gay to
Marxist I might believe that but I
definitely am not going to believe that
Tom fit and his friends [__] right [__]
and so what ended up happening was he
was like I got the number from someone
that is associated with something you
say okay so sorry Associated yeah he he
is an acquaintance right and so what uh
what he said was he's like I got the
number from them but you wouldn't be
surprised the amount of [__] that they
talk behind Tom Finn's back well yeah
because he can't where a shirt that fits
him uh the chat is asking of what spaces
are so Twitter has like a um an audio
room where it's it's like a it's like
kind of like a conference room where
people can listen in it's almost like a
audio Zoom call on Twitter yeah and then
you can use the app clubhouse that was
just like that's exactly that's a that's
a great example Tony it's it's a zoom
call on Twitter is whatever right right
with no with no video just audio and
people are talking back and forth I
think there's usually like 10 or 11
people that are on stage quote unquote
that have the microphone that are
speakers
um so if anyone wants to come to these
[__] crazy ass bases what's what's
his name what's the name of the guy who
holds it because he held all yeah Mario
Mario uh he holds all he yelled all the
Twitter and I I you know I don't have uh
much good to say about Mario other than
he will hold these faces and he'll allow
people with opinion that is not his it
appears uh in the spaces to to to rebut
these morons now it really is a
right-wing space don't get it twisted
um it is a right-wing space that's
that's the Crux of it that's the
narrative that's the the drive of it but
he does let folks in and uh and to Texas
Paul there's a there's some news
breaking out of that Twitter space
yesterday because what happened was is
Leb Parnes do you know who lead Parnes
is you remember this absolutely yeah so
Rudy Giuliani was in this space before
and then Leb Parnes comes in Texas Paul
and apparently Leb Parnes drops [__]
news about Hunter Biden's laptop and
Rudy Giuliani can you believe that what
what would make you think that Rudy
Giuliani had anything to do with all
this [__] with Hunter Biden's laptop
that doesn't exist
I tell you what Rudy Julia Giuliani is
in sheer Terror because you know with
with with all of this this is going this
is going to court there's no way that
that blind dummy computer guy is going
to be able to settle with Hunter Biden
over this lawsuit this is all going to
come out I mean this guy's not going to
take the fall for Rudy [__] Giuliani
he's not gonna do it he's just not going
to do it and and Rudy's screwed I mean
he is screwed he's already on thin ice
with the bar he's he's done man he is
done this guy Rudy took the took this
laptop from
this how the hell a blind guy works on
computers I don't know I I don't know
and then he took and added a bunch of
[__] to the hard drive apparently and
and you know like we keep seeing all
these pictures and whatnot and and
Hunter's like
that wasn't my party
that was my party but that wasn't my
party you know I mean they put a bunch
of [__] on the damn hard drive and made
it useless as far as evidence is
concerned because they totally screwed
the chain of custody of the thing up but
yeah I mean it's just Rudy is a freaking
[__] he is I am starting to believe
that back in the day when Rudy made his
bones about uh Prosecuting the mob that
he may have actually been working for
the Russian mob well I'll tell you that
lepparn has said in the in the space he
said there is a Rudy of old and there is
a Rudy of new this new Rudy is not the
mayor that you know that's not the guy
he has changed it's been [__] over 20
years since he was the mayor of New York
City and he's just not that guy anymore
he's the guy now who is a trump Lackey
and he would do anything to make sure
Trump remained president United States
including blackmailing Ukraine and using
Hunter buying's laptop as a as a as a
weapon against Joe Biden which is
hilarious because they're still trying
to use it and um and I'm not sure
exactly what was said because I wasn't I
was in the space when lead was there but
it was later on when they were saying
this stuff Gabe or that he was saying
this stuff but I do want to point out um
one one thing that they were saying in
space because they were kind of laughing
level lab off because he was like look I
have the evidence and they kept laughing
him off oh well if you had evidence
you'd present it in court and you'd
present it to the federal prosecutors
here's the thing folks I want to tell
you about Federal prosecutions and I
want to tell you about plea deals when
you take a plea deal you don't go to
trial your Discovery or your evidence is
not laid before the public in a trial so
anything that led Parnes presented to
the prosecutors to get that deal in a
proper about Rudy Giuliani that evidence
does doesn't necessarily mean we know or
don't know that the evidence that he
gave to get that plea now I will say
this I will say this that that it is
interesting that LEP Barnes is claiming
that he has he has evidence that shows
that Rudy had anything to do with
Leonard bind's laptop and this [__]
about it
um and the reason why I think it's
interesting is because Maga has been
yelling and screaming for [__] years
about how Hunter Biden hasn't been
prosecuted you did over this laptop yet
but let me tell you if the pros if the
feds have evidence that shows that
Hunter Biden didn't do what they claim
he did because they have evidence from
lip Barnes that would give them reason
um not to prosecute Hunter Biden because
just as feds and prosecutors collect
evidence of why people are guilty when
they get evidence of people that are not
guilty they don't pursue that case
that's why this case in New York is so
important is because Alvin Bragg had the
dea's office has something that is going
to make them believe that the grand jury
not only will vote for a felony but they
in court will be able to get a jury
convinced with this evidence that they
will convict him of a felony now rather
that happens or not that's that's for
the system to work out that's the whole
[__] point Trump is innocent until
proven guilty I mean if you believe he's
innocent but that's the point so when
when we start when we start down this
road of oh there's because Tom Fenton
would say it Seb would say it that
stupid gym [__] I don't know he
is somehow he's tied to Joe Walsh he was
saying it there's no way that that
there's any evidence against Trump I'm
like you're a dumb [__] and this
is a grand jury this is a grand jury
making this vote not Alvin Bragg
bringing charges against Trump without a
grand jury because Alvin Bragg could do
that Alvin Bragg as the as the Manhattan
D.A could say [__] the grand jury I'm
just gonna charge him and then go to
court with that charge but the point is
is that Alvin Bragg wants to go to court
with a grand jury vote with the evidence
that he has laid before them that's what
he wants and the reason why is because
it gives the prosecutors a strong
position to convict on the charge that
they are trying to indict it's it it's
amazing to me that these people don't
understand this Texas Paul it's a crazy
it's insane I mean it's just uh the
whole thing is just so wide out in the
open too I mean it's not like this is
hard to understand I mean it's just I I
really don't get
you know like Rudy Jew Rudy giuliani's
involvement in this I mean and and Bob
Costello's I mean I just
all of these people are just tied in
together
talking [__] and what's worse is I
don't know if you've been following
what's been going on the prosecutor that
was with the doj one of the things
Republicans are saying is oh the
Republicans the doj didn't didn't
prosecute this well the prosecutor that
was working on this case that handed all
his evidence over to Alvin Bragg
I mean there's a lot more there has come
out publicly and said Bill Barr tried to
shut my case down Bill Barr interfered
with my investigation Bill Barr would
not allow me to file charges I have to
get approval from my boss before I walk
into court and he would not let me do it
Bill Barr went so far as to try to get
uh Cohen's conviction overturned
he wanted this to go away I mean this is
another thing that's just blowing up all
over the place with this case because
everybody's like well why didn't the doj
pursue this I mean a lot of this you
know the federal prosecutors have
purview here
um
Bill Barr Bill Barr is the reason and
and you've just got that whole cabal put
together you've got Bannon that was
working for Trump Giuliani that was
working for cabal did you say cabal
because Marjorie Taylor green says cable
I just want to make sure
demonic cable
you know I hate to be mock this at every
turn but really honestly their their
narrative and their plot line is falling
apart and the reason why is because it's
all based on stupidity dumb [__] and
lies
um and if you guys want to join uh the
space later on I think I'm gonna try to
make time to be in there for a little
bit I'm not sure what time I'll be in
there that some [__] will probably be
eight or nine hours I'm sure I mean
yesterday was 10 hours was it 10 hours
this space um
yeah because I jumped in uh just to add
context for the whole like Rudy Giuliani
left harness part so I was I jumped it I
left because I like said my I was on
there for hours and I was like all right
I gotta do all this stuff now uh and
then I came back on later and I happened
to just come right in when Lev parnis
was telling kim.com who is a is a Putin
supporter uh tim.com was there yeah well
he's always there
and it's uh he so it's it was amazing to
hear everyone just shut the [__] up on
that call well hey let me ask you at
that point was was it Ed or Brian in the
room do you remember Ed Ed was in the
room in that time I think Ed was in the
room because I'm on oh okay so Ryan was
in earlier Ed came in or it might have
been tell the audience about Ed and
Brian because they were in the room but
I'm trying to get either Ed or Brian
because they wrote a story this morning
about what happened in the room with lit
Barnes and the 100 lamped up [__] so
uh Ed and Brian uh they're twins
um they're I guess they were I guess
just let back on Twitter not too long
ago
um they became well known for a lot of
reasons one of them was they would
always be like one of the first people
to reply to Trump when he would post
actually I'm gonna have Ed right now
I've got Ed right now right I'm gonna
try to get him on here here in just a
second so basically yeah so just to
quickly give you a backstory I came in
Lev basically shut down the conversation
everyone tried to push all these uh you
you crane conspiracy theories and things
about him and he was like I don't know
where you get in this news but I can
tell you straight up right now from my
own experience this is not true and then
they started to push other conspiracies
of like uh
and Trump evicted him from a condo he's
like I don't know where you got that but
I've never been evicted from a condo
from Trump my son doesn't work for Mike
Pence or never tried to work for Mike
Pence it was and then but it was this
woman who's like a right-wing kind of
journalist who was saying like oh I did
I have people close by he's like okay
well I'm telling you right now that
that's not true so if you were a good
journalist or a good reporter you would
do due diligence and you would figure
out exactly who these sources were he's
like can you tell me the sources can you
verify this stuff can you show me proof
and then this is when this this
bombshell dropped he talks about a video
between uh him it's like a zoom Skype
call between him and Rudy Giuliani and I
got Ed here now
um so let's let's see if Ed can tell us
about what was happening in the room uh
when Lev said this and and him and his
brother have written a story on this
today uh so Ed uh welcome to the Tony
Michaels podcast I appreciate you
joining us last minute here we're talk
talking about you in this room and what
you were hearing that led Barnes but
tell us about your story and tell us
about what the hell he was saying about
the hunter buying lamp that and why it's
significant to Rudy Giuliani yeah so I
mean for those who don't know parnis was
working with Rudy Giuliani back in 2017
through 2019 when they split ways and
partners was arrested he was arrested
because for multiple things it had to do
with Ukraine and also had to deal with
some business dealings he was making he
ended up going to prison he's now in
home confinement uh
ultimately he was convicted of wire
fraud and making false statements what
what he didn't he plead guilty he didn't
he wasn't convicted he pled guilty right
he pled guilty and it was re actually in
regards to money that he essentially
funneled to the to the trump super Pac
was Russian money that was he he said it
was co-mingled with his money and then
transferred to Russia he also claimed he
transferred money to Iran to santis and
other politicians as well he said he's
going to release more information on
that and proof and evidence of it at a
later date but getting back to the whole
Hunter Biden laptop scenario or or the
events that took place there
he he's he said that he was asked by
Trump and Giuliani to go find dirt on
Hunter Biden
about barisma about uh the prosecutor
General Victor shoken he ended up saying
that he didn't actually find dirt and it
ended up he actually debunked it all and
it it wasn't true uh shokun wasn't ever
investigating barisma for those who are
familiar with that story
but as far as that laptop goes
Giuliani found out I think was in June
of yeah that's June of 2019 they were
parnis Giuliani and a Russian asset that
harness isn't yet ready to name we're
having dinner and that Russian asset
informed parnis and Giuliani that this
laptop existed and that Hunter Biden was
actually drugged by the FSB and the
founder of barisma he was drug provided
prostitutes and then his laptop was
stolen and this took place according to
Partners in Kazakhstan Biden was going
to Kazakhstan to meet a minister I think
when he said Minister it's like a
minister of defense minister I believe
it might have even been that Minister
may have been the founder of barisma
because he's also a minister in Ukraine
or was at the time
and this happened in June of 2019 in
October of 2019 harness was boarding a
flight to Vienna wit and Giuliani was
supposed to meet them there as well
harness and his partner Igor frumin were
boarding this plane and that's when they
got arrested and Giuliani at the time
told the Atlantic that
that he was also going to Vienna but it
had nothing to do with frumin and uh
fumin and parnish certainly not she's
all fishy but that's how that story goes
he he claims that this laptop existed
they knew it existed Trump knew it
exists and that was their goal to get up
get their hands on it and then a year
later that laptop Giuliani says he gets
it from this repair shop turns it over
to New York Post the repair shop owner
says that Hunter Biden brought the
laptop in signed the contract for the
repair and the rest is history
uh here is here I got that on the screen
here and let me pull it up here's your
tweet this morning about this story that
you guys have from the from the space
that Lev was in and he dropped it I I
don't think we've ever heard this
um this information publicly about uh
the hunter Biden laptop story and the
[__] about it I mean you know we've
known we've known for ever that the
right is really concerned with with the
laptop oh it's all about the laptop I
mean they really want to see Hunter
Biden's dick picks it seems like
um but I mean that's what they're really
truly interested in I think I don't
think they're interested in Russia or
China or you know collusion or political
corruption they just want to see how big
his hog is
um I mean they seem you know very
obsessed with genitalia in the first
place so why wouldn't they want to see
his
um but you have this on uh your I think
it's your sub stack is that right oh
yeah yeah yeah so you can go
um follow Ed on Twitter here's his uh
Twitter handle here there's his Twitter
handle there uh at e d k r a s s e n and
follows his brother Brian as well
um but this is your guys's sub stack as
far as this bombshell allegation and I
think also that space was recorded so
you can probably go listen to that space
somewhere too
um
there's a 10-hour Twitter space yeah so
you're gonna have to get to the very end
how late was it in there because I was
in there when Leb was in there but it
was when they were like they were like
uh he kept saying look I've got receipts
and like hahaha what are you a teenage
girl with receipts and then he's like
okay [__] and apparently I wasn't
there when it happened but apparently he
dropped some of them because one of the
things that he said during this because
I happen to just I I Tony and I were in
there earlier with with uh with Ed and
then I jump back in later in the later
in the late night I want to say like
eight 8 30 maybe I don't know like
Pacific time is probably when this
conversation really started to uh evolve
into this uh Hunter Biden laptop because
one of the things he said was
people are like oh this is just your
opinion right this is just your opinion
you don't actually have evidence he's
like I've got a video call it was like a
Skype video call that he kept
referencing between him and Rudy
Giuliani he said that no one's ever seen
before okay wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait
if there is a [__] Zoom call that
exists of Rudy Giuliani talking about
lib Barnes about Hunter Biden's laptop
and how they're going to make this into
let me tell you something I don't give a
I don't give a [__] about indictments I
want to see that video that's the video
I want to see Ed can you get into this
video can you so so number one Giuliani
was actually in the Twitter space as
well but it was well before that and
then the the video there's a video that
he that Partners claims to have of the
prosecutor general of in Ukraine
basically admitting that he was never
investigating verisma and he was telling
this to Giuliani and parnis on tape so
that's some evidence that he claims he
has he also claims to have text messages
from various people people uh he said he
got a letter in prison
from the hotel when Anthony was arrested
did he talk about that already no no no
yeah no yeah but it was a postcard
because I remember yeah yeah a postcard
from the White House from Trump and
Giuliani saying don't talk you'll be
okay and then the next day I believe it
was next day or soon thereafter uh
Trump's personal attorney uh John Day
Out showed up at prison along with Paul
Mana for its attorney Downing I believe
is Kevin Downing and they basically told
him
to keep his mouth shut don't say
anything and harness fired John Dowd at
that point he started he began realizing
like okay what did I get myself into and
now he now he's in home confinement he
wants to you know get some more of this
information out Congress led by
Republicans now he doesn't believe they
want him to testify oh hell no they
don't they don't want that they don't
want that evidence out in the open
um you know here's here's the thing is
that um in this space and and if you
want to go see these spaces they've
invited me they they probably invited
you Ed and your brother and probably
Gabe to come back to this space um
because I had to Mario's defense
although I don't want to I don't want to
give too much defense to him he does
allow non-right-wingers uh people who
are you know antifa as it were or antifa
we're the antibi cabal uh into the room
uh to actually push back on lies and the
misinformation and just the absolute
garbage that these people talk about in
this room
um so I do I do give him a little bit of
credit for that but I I don't want to
give Mario too much credit here and
because I want to give Mario credit too
go ahead go ahead no no we can have
different weapons he tries to get more
left-wing people in his room but they
won't come in there they don't they
won't go well I'll tell you if you if if
you're a lefty out there which I know
you're you at least have some sort of
sympathy towards liberalism
um at least if you're watching this show
or if you're a [__] troll you might
be a hate hate watching we got a lot of
hate Watchers here too either way
whether you're a hate Watcher and you
love these white right-wing nut jobs or
if you want to come listen to a little
bit of Truth
um just follow me at the Tony Michaels
you can follow Gabe Sanchez at I am Gabe
Sanchez and if we're in this room what
happens or you can follow Ed and what
happens when we're in this room there's
like a white circle that happens around
your your avatar on Twitter and it has
like a little microphone that means
we're in that room uh either listening
or speaking and you can just click in
that room and I'll try to retweet it
this time I don't really do it much
because I'm like hey I don't want I
don't want people know I'm in here you
know uh trying to beat back on this
Mission it's kind of fun though it's
kind of fun it's pretty it gets it gets
pretty Saturday yesterday went pretty
wild like despite the fact of presenting
you know facts right you still have
people who say Jan 6 was an Insurrection
Rudy Giuliani wasn't lying they actually
had evidence like they'll they'll keep
beating that drum uh you know Seb Gorka
and Tom fit and all these people they'll
continue to push this idea
you know I I will say this like it does
it is annoying in ways that it's like oh
that this is like non-stop they they
will continue down this path
but at the same time I'm like well you
know if I'm not saying it then maybe
someone else wants like if Tony's not
saying it or Ed's not saying or I'm not
saying like maybe yeah no one's going to
be in the room so like it it it does get
frustrating to be like Jesus like how
how like how hard are you willing to hit
your head against the wall this many
times and not be willing to accept court
documents because uh you know
depositions testimonies actual facts
statistics data like whatever it is and
be like nope I mean you know yesterday
there was one guy who's like I won't
even look at the fox files I won't
accept the fact yeah because it doesn't
support their narrative it doesn't
support their delusion so as frustrating
it is that cracks me up so much it's
like fox says we're lying to you and
their viewers are like no you're not no
you're not and they're like no really
we're lying to you and they're like well
I'm not gonna watch if you're not gonna
tell me that you're not lying to me
because they want to be lied to they
want to be lied to that's part of this
space that's part of their that's part
of Ebbs uh his [__] circus that's
part of Tom Fenton's [__] he doesn't
believe this garbage he's just puking it
up for the Cheeto dust q and honor
that's what he's doing that's the
intention because when they say oh this
this trial and this indictment is
political you damn right it's political
Trump made it political it's about
politics it's about a campaign every
crime that this guy is accused of
investigated for is political because he
made it political he he [__] he's the
one who incited the riot at January 6 to
try to overthrow our government when he
lost the election that he ran for in a
political campaign what the [__] is it
political about this I I just can't
understand how they don't get it through
their thick heads that yes it is
political because it him doing making
committing political crimes what don't
you understand about it um you know what
I find interesting is the fact that
Hunter Biden is now suing John Paul Mack
I believe that's his name the the repair
air shop owner right and in that lawsuit
they're requesting that Rudy Giuliani
and Steve Bannon I believe be deposed so
if they can get everything under oath
and question about some of these
allegations that paranus has made and
some of these other allegations about
the laptop they can they can either you
know get him on a lie or find out the
truth about really what happened right I
think that's big I think that's probably
what the real purpose of this of this uh
of the hymn of Biden suing the parashop
owner is I don't think it's really to
you know get money out of it I don't
think the repair shop owner probably has
much money I think it's to basically let
the truth get out there because if if
Hunter Biden just went to the media and
released stuff it wouldn't hold any
weight but if if it's done in a court of
law where these people are under oath
then you know I think it kind of can
dispel some of these myths that the the
Republicans especially Congressional
Republicans have and that was that was
something that Lev said last night he
was like look I don't I can't speculate
how the laptop got from
Kazakhstan to the repair shop like I
don't know who who handed it off right
because there was a lot of doubt I was
like how does a Blind repair shop owner
know that it was Hunter Biden and know
to give to Drew Giuliani right but if in
2019 the conversation is already
happening before it gets its way over to
the repair shop that Rudy Giuliani knows
or hears Whispers and talks to Lev about
it you know there begins to you begin to
have questions like all right well if
you knew about it beforehand how did you
know to contact this repair shop this
blind computer repair shop owner
to get the laptop right yeah and I mean
hunter Biden's signatures on the
contract when he took it in to get
repaired I mean could that have been
forged somehow could like you could they
have gotten Hunter to sign it somehow
could they have you know just made a
photocopy and put his yeah put his
signature on there and made another
photocopy of it with that glued on there
who knows I mean I mean that's all you
know speculation I guess you could say
conspiracy at this point it I tell you
what man this whole operation goes back
to the beginning if you if you look at
what Hunter Biden does for a living I
mean he he advises company everybody was
like they I mean they had this whole
narrative planned out this is why we
need to be far more aggressive on our
side because if you look at what they
had I mean am I not aggressive enough no
we're not aggressive enough we need to
be much hotter on this because I'm
telling you Tony from the get-go
I am telling you from the get-go Hunter
Biden advises companies like marisma
they had their well why was Hunter Biden
on the board of an oil company because
the oil company needed Western financing
and that's what Hunter Biden does for a
living
he puts he put harness touched on like
what the reasoning that Biden was on the
board and it was basically because they
wanted protection and it and they and
what part of said is that Biden wasn't
even aware of what was going on at this
point like he he wasn't aware of the
real reasons why they wanted it they
kind of they kind of tricked him into
into joining verisma I think they went
after a couple other guys and they
turned it down and they knew that they
had Hunter Biden on barisma
the United States government would be
more protective of the company so so I
mean like looking at it that's where you
know that's partially true but the idea
that Hunter Biden was you know
working for barisma to make money for
Joe Biden it seems like that's not what
actually took place no and that's
exactly what I was saying it is is that
that was his job I mean the reason
Victor shulkin went down is because
Western you know financing will not move
into a country when you have somebody
like shoken running the show they're not
going to do it they cannot guarantee
their Investments when you've got
somebody who is willing to to be that
dirty they're not going to do it Victor
shokun had to go if Ukraine was going to
get Western investment that is literally
what what Hunter Biden does for a living
he he
basically sells this protection he tells
people how you want you want the West to
fall under that curtain you want to then
you have to follow the rules that go on
in that room and and the rules include
guys like shoken have to go
you can't have them and and
it's like Swift boating all over again
the the Republicans took something
that's a good thing
you know you've got the Ukraine moving
from uh post-soviet state to a Western
European country
and that they came at
the bidens with one of their great
strengths this should have been a great
story on our side the bidens help a
post-soviet with a the Bread Basket of
frickin Europe help them come across to
to the to the light they brought them
into the light that should have been our
story that should have been our
narrative but they I mean as soon as
this broke they were already ready they
were already ready with this [__]
and I'm telling you man we have to be
more aggressive we have to I'll tell you
that all the all the all the hunter
Biden dick pic lovers out there in the
chat they think we're fools to oh my God
I mean they really like Hunter Hunter
Biden's dick pics but they don't like
how we talk about it Ed I appreciate you
joining us we have to get to some video
I got to show the audience some crazy
ass clips that's going on so I've I've
got I've got to let you go I appreciate
you joining us on last minute but give
us a Shameless plug if you can tell our
audience where to find this uh article
about what led Barnes said yeah I just
go to
crestonstine.news and I think is the
second article the first article an
article about Tara Reid that we that's
we've had that feature for a while but
yeah just go there and you can read the
article I don't really have anything
else you plug but thanks for having me
on and yeah sure come back come back
anytime maybe we'll see in the space uh
later on today if uh if you're before
you go can I say one thing to you sure I
am here today because of you and your
brother in in no small part you guys
were out there swinging for the longest
time y'all took so much [__] and so many
attacks because there just weren't a
whole lot of us out there you guys were
standing up in the [__] Storm from
the get-go and I'm telling you that's
why I started screaming into a
microphone because I'm like hey you know
we're all talking about this but
nobody's freaking saying it man and you
guys were the ins were part of the
inspiration you know you Jeff teedrich
guys like you were out there by
yourselves man you know and I just
wanted to take the opportunity to say
how much I appreciate you about it yeah
well thank you everybody for joining us
appreciate it come back anytime
um again maybe we'll see we'll see you
in the space later everybody thank you
for coming we'll uh we'll be back with
more Clips we're gonna watch these crazy
ass clips of these crazy right ringers
right after this stick around we'll be
right back right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
wait was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we have plenty of Slam jams skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one in
your absence I discovered a rash on my
neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
here's Tammy
[__] um
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show
always I got some clips I want to show
you
first thing I want you to do is hit
subscribe down there on YouTube if
you're on YouTube if you're on Twitch
follow us there
and if you're on Facebook go over to at
the Tony Michaels and follow us on
Facebook don't be [__] around all
that [__] is free because this show is
free every single weekday noon Eastern
11 Central 9 Pacific for two full hours
um here's Lindsey Graham's take fellas
uh from this morning about how this is
going to rip the country apart let's
let's listen to old lady G and then uh
we'll break it down here so are you
concerned about the uh district attorney
Bragg Alvin Bragg indicting president
Trump next week in an unprecedented way
and the circus it would be around that
yeah it's going to blow up our country
and this is a bunch of idiots you've had
the prosecutor before brag Mr Vance look
at the case and pass on it you had the
U.S attorney in New York say I'm not
going to do it federally there was an
intervening cause other than Trump
running one of the guys in the DA's
office wrote a book very critical events
you should have prosecuted Trump you let
him off and Brad feels that pressure
he's a George Soros back prosecutor he
can't take the heat so the guys yielding
to the political pressure generated by
the former prosecutor and this is a case
without Merit in my view Donald Trump
will be the only person in the history
of New York prosecuted under this Theory
okay so here's the thing fellas if this
is really going to blow up our country
shouldn't Lindsey Graham and the
Republican Party be calling for Donald
Trump to stop his political campaign and
to handle his his personal legal issues
and then and then once he gets those
done and he's done with that then he can
come back and and run in their party
shouldn't that be what there shouldn't
that be I mean if it really truly is
Donald Trump running and having to
defend off criminal indictments here
because he crimed and he kept criming
shouldn't shouldn't the Republican party
just say hey man hey Grandpa take a seat
this cycle you can come back in 2028 if
you haven't been killed by Big Macs by
then or you're not in prison I mean
let's do that but they're not doing that
and the reason why is because it's all
nonsense Lindsey Grahams knows his
nonsense and the sore
[__] that's more he's a Jew and that's
what that is I don't give a [__] what
you say that's what they're saying when
they say that [__] what do you think
Texas well what do you think a ladies
G's analysis here of the of the of the
Sorrows back D.A
I'm actually surprised he's out there
saying anything at all because he is
really screwed when finally gets going
because I mean he's one of the people
making the phone calls for Trump trying
to get those votes Down to Georgia I was
actually just shocked to see that he's
putting his face out there again because
uh you know for for a while there he was
nice and quiet but you know this is
[__] it's just [__] look at look
at you know we were supposed to have all
these protests and all this other
[__] it's just not happening and
people really really pay attention when
something this big you can't argue it
you just can't make [__] up there's
court record you know it's like the fox
thing it's why they stick their fingers
in their ears
every time you talk to him about Fox
because it's just a matter of record and
they cannot maintain their their bubble
their their false reality when you have
court testimony where these people just
can't lie you know they just just can't
lie they face repercussions when they
lie in court it's not like lying on Fox
News you know and to say nobody's been
prosecuted on this is [__] it is
[__] you know I mean I'm sorry but I
happen to know a guy that went to prison
over this
yeah I happen to know a guy that went to
prison over this you know it's it's it's
I I'm really just I I um you know I just
started looking at the at the old
comments like I said to keep going going
back to John Edwards and and the [__] he
was prosecuted for these same people the
same [__] Lindsey Graham was saying
that John Edwards you know they need to
you know they were trying to have
decorum because he was a former Senator
but he was saying well this needs to be
looked at and looked at hard I mean it's
just
the hypocrisy is just it's gobsmacking
Tony it really is oh speaking of Gob
smack to hypocrisy here's old bunny ears
uh Gabe's favorite dude um Donald Trump
Jr you know what's funny again I keep
saying they're losing the plot line and
they they've got a hundred stories of
why this is the way it is and all of
them contradict each other
um and here Donald Trump doesn't Junior
does not let us down here and absolutely
letting the the plot slip through his
coat is coke uh stained fingers here are
his um his uh cocaine fingernail or
crested fingernails here it lets it slip
through the cracks here but here here he
is on his is this the is this the
official show now yeah so we turned in
his Coke rages into an actual show is
that what this is uh he still does the
coke rages on Facebook but he has
triggered the podcast which is where
he's triggered where he's triggered but
it's the same
why would he call it that really
honestly because they're always like you
Liberals are so triggered so I'm gonna
have a podcast where I'm nothing but
triggered and call it triggered this is
ridiculous Okay let's listen to how he's
triggered here by Ron DeSantis this is
great folks if you're not aware of the
wedges that we can draw between Ron
desantos and Donald Trump you are not
paying attention this is fabulous watch
where's
that's what it is guys he's owned by the
billionaire donors 100
controlled opposition let's see which
way the wind is blowing let's see which
way they want me to respond and I will
do it so I was hoping for a strong
response but we got a milk toast
response we got weaker than most Rhino
Republicans we got a weaker response
than a lot of never Trump Republicans
and guys
here's the deal
you can hire influencers to post videos
of you dunking on what was like a hot
Twitter take 10 days ago on some more on
local reporter what what is this guy
other than some [__] influencer I
mean what has he done in his life that
wasn't given that's it uh I know right I
know also is he talking about us like I
don't know who's he talking you know I
have no idea no I think he's talking
about Republicans who aren't defending
Trump the way that they want him to
defend Trump the way that DeSantis
didn't do the other day DeSantis the
other day he's like well I don't know
anything about having sex with porn
stars and then paying them hush money
because I gotta cover it up because I'm
running a presidential campaign wink
like so passive aggressive and then
Trump trump post on social media he
actually put the minus touch post with
minus touch his logo and everything on
it he's like Rhonda Santos is a
pedophile like I'm like God damn it
you're not paying attention to how these
idiots are gonna lose the 2024 general
election you're you're just you got your
head up your ass this is fabulous [__]
the indictments I don't I don't give a
[__] if there's 12 of them there's one
of them I don't care if they fail I
don't care if we get to try or there's a
perp walk let me tell you something this
is making them [__] nuts because they
can't pick out why this is happening
they can't figure out why they're in
such trouble and they can't figure out
how this is killing their party and
their chances to win in 2024 against
sleepy Joe Biden I mean they're
literally giving it to us listen you can
get plenty of people to do that as Ron
has
but that doesn't make you ready for the
big leagues if you can't understand that
this is a fundamental issue of our time
then you're not ready then it's not your
time as even people like Mike cernovich
who have been big DeSantis supporters
just heartbroken that DeSantis doesn't
understand what Soros DA's and the
Bolsheviks are going to do to this
country oh my god when I watch this
video this is the thing that [__] got
me the most he's he said the word
Bolsheviks uh now now a lot of people
know what who the Bolsheviks are Texas
Paul a lot of people know the Bolsheviks
are so people who may have studied Uh
Russian history and how they how Lenin
came to power as the as the Bolsheviks
Communists came to power but let me tell
you 99.9 of Americans don't know what
the [__] that word means who the [__]
they are and wouldn't understand even if
you gave him a history lesson it is I
can't even believe they are in in in so
deep on their delusion that they're
using words to call Americans Bolsheviks
Texas ball what do you make of that it's
[__] crazy to me uh I saw uh God damn
it I can't he's such a nobody I can't
remember his name Portillo I think his
name is he was one of the guys that was
at the the malware uh bird sanctuary
[__] with Clive and Bundy he's he's like
big in the right-wing circles talking
about Nikolai
I mean they're they're trying
desperately to seem like they're they're
intellectuals this guy has no freaking
clue the chai chesku was the soviet's
boy and the and that Putin wants the
Soviet Union all over again this is
their [__] guy you know I mean they
have no clue what they're talking about
they don't know the the difference
between the Reds and the whites in the
Russian Revolution they have no idea
what they're talking about they just
have words like when they say Soros
they're they're saying Jewish that's
what they're saying right well you know
you know what's funny about this you
know what proves to me why they're
switching to the word Bolshevik the
reason why they're switching to it as if
there's some violent Communist
Revolution in this country like what the
[__] are you talking about like there's
no I mean at best the actual Communists
in this country [__] hate Joe Biden
they [__] hate Democrats the actual
Communists anyone who identifies
themselves or their ideology is kind
communities they don't like the
Democratic party you [__] Rubes
you're a dumb [__] if you think they do
you're not paying attention but the
craziest part is is that socialist and
communist is not working those those
it's not working it's not working inside
their plot line because no one buys that
[__] that there's a bunch of
Communists running our government when
the actual Communists [__] hate Joe
Biden like they [__] hate him the
social Jesus Christ even the Democratic
socialists for for all intents and
purposes does not like Joe Biden he's
too moderate for him but that's just
that's just where we are in our
political landscape but I can't even I
cannot tell you how excited it makes me
excited that Donald Trump Jr has
switched from the word radical left
communist Marxist to Bolsheviks that is
that folks it is if you do not
understand why that is so important what
is most important is not only does
Donald Trump not understand that average
and average Americans don't understand
that and I'll guaran damn to you that
manga has no [__] clue what he is
talking about when he says Bolsheviks
and they've lost the plot line of it's
crazy left-wing Marxist Communists are
taking over the country that's all it
proves to me and I'm excited about it
that that piece of tape got me really
[__] excited when he said that
yeah I mean yeah you've got you've got
Joe Biden who's to the right of Center
he is he is he is to the right he's not
a liberal he's a conservative he is I
mean look at ask anybody in any of the
trade unions I asked the railroad to
unions about Joe Biden and they will
tell you this is not a left guy you know
I mean it's it's
working that was the whole argument
against him and that that's been the
argument for two years that's their
argument of why they want someone to
[__] to to primary him in the
Democratic uh primary which won't work
doesn't matter what you say it won't
work it's not how Democratic primaries
work if if you're not understanding how
the incumbent president gets to have
super delegates and Democrats have super
delegates for that reason and that
reason most you are a bonehead and
you're not aware of how our system works
you just don't know you need to learn a
little bit that's what you need to do
but I mean that's you know we live in a
time where this is the guy this is the
guy who is the leader of people who
think they're [__] intellectuals not
only the intellectuals Gabe Sanchez
they're trying they're railroad experts
they're [__] epidemiologists they're
[__] economic experts they're Bank
experts I mean it's like every day they
wake up in this country and they have a
whole new degree and a whole new career
as some sort of Internet expert on this
or that well yeah I mean the the ability
to jump from armchair expert on one
field to another field within hours is
amazing like the fact that people were
able to become epidemiologists during
covid within just a few short weeks was
amazing because the people who actually
were epidemiologists like well why did I
spend all this money on the school in
all these years right do you guys
already have the answer right just you
just throw the Ivermectin Facebook group
and you'll learn everything you need to
know about epidemiology right like you
see people in the Twitter spaces and
other places where they're like oh well
that's not how ndas work and that's not
this and that's not this this is a
felony and this is a misdemeanor not a
you know the ability for people to speak
with
in some of these spaces I mean it
happens on the left too but I mean like
in some of these spaces that we've been
in but also online with like this
it's uh it's impressive the amount of
confidence that they have right to say
without any any evidence any proof any
knowledge to be like this this case with
Trump is [__]
and what a lot of us on this space are
saying or at least attempting to say
is say look we don't know we we only
know a little bit of what's going on
right like if Alvin Bragg came in office
and said look there's no case here and
two people resigned to say we actually
do have felonies uh that can be charged
and then Alvin Bragg comes back later
whether it's new evidence or going back
through and saying oh actually this is a
case right like we have no idea what is
actually involved here just the same way
that people wanted to use Costello to be
like Costello was brought in he was so
pissed off castello's know [__] about
what anyone else said during the grand
jury he's only privy to the questions he
was asked into the evidence that may
have been presented that he could refute
or corroborate with nothing else when
you do a grand jury you oh the only
other people who know everything are the
actual jury members themselves right you
have the people in the court prosecution
defense you have the people who are
asking questions but the person who's
brought up to be like hey here's a
question here's a question they are only
privy they own and for those who don't
know privy means I only know what is
around me in that moment I'm only able
to know you only know what you know you
don't know what you don't know so well
and this guy doesn't this guy doesn't
know a lot I gotta show some clips I
gotta show some clips here I want to
show this clip and I want to get to the
part of the clip
um of Costello coming out and giving a
press conference afterwards and giving
away his cards like at least he should
have not said anything and we wouldn't
know the public of what [__] bad
position Trump he put Trump in and Trump
did it himself but and I'm going to show
a Jimmy Kimmel clip here too I think
even though they're gonna knock us on
Facebook I'm gonna show it because he
lays it out so perfectly of what's going
on but here's here's Trump this is crazy
it's a minute and a half I'm not going
to show the whole thing but just listen
to this [__] absolute unhinged words
out and see if you can make sense of it
these four horrible radical left
Democrat investigations of your all-time
favorite President oh my God is
just a disgusting Witch Hunt in the
history of our country it's gone on
forever with Russia Russia Russia and
Ukraine Ukraine Ukraine there's one of
my crimes there's two of crimes it's an
absolute disgrace what's going on they
even spied on my campaign because he was
colluding with Russia there's another
crime
of the work that they did on Mueller no
collusion that's what the answer was
more crime he's admitting to you more
crime he's projecting the Mar-A-Lago
race there's another crime select
committee hoax there's another crime
there's another crime
stormy horse face oh put another crime
on the books
ah God damn
all sickness already hey hey Grandpa hey
Grandpa let me give you a piece of
advice stop criming that'll help that'll
[__] help a little bit you know what
I mean Jesus Christ reminds me that
who reminds me a liar liar stop breaking
the law [__]
[Laughter]
I put in Sean Hannity like he's giving
him a good right because Sean Hannity
rules all his crime and he just did he
did another one last week I think it was
where he was like let's roll the footage
and it's like dude why are you doing
this we're just showing everyone to be
like look these are all the things to be
investigated for for for for for for uh
for cause right for just cause he's
being investigated for just cause the
idea that you would play the things that
you think are going to help him it
wouldn't be the crimes that he's
committing yeah you show up something oh
they're coming after him unfairly for
this don't break up the actual [__] that
they're investing for him because they
have actual crimes
well here's here's a little bit from
Costello uh yesterday after he testified
and it was unsuccessful and I believe it
was unsuccessful because they had
Michael Cohen ready to rebut him but
they didn't even need to rebut him and
really I think uh Bragg's office uh
baited Trump into doing this into giving
away his cards because he's a [__]
idiot and I I believe that I believe
that Trump probably has something on
this dumb ass and and Trump thought it
was a good idea I doubt his attorneys
thought this was a good idea and if he
did his attorneys are [__] um but
here's here's Costello after he came out
of the Grand Jury Room I'm not going to
show the clip but Joe Reed because we're
running out of time on the other side
where Glenn gives a little analysis of
this but listen to what Costello's is
Michael Cohn told us that he was
approached by Stormy Daniels lawyer and
Stormy Daniels had negative information
that she wanted to put in a lawsuit
against Trump so Michael Cohen decided
on his own that's what he told us on his
own to see if he could take care of this
so he sat with the lawyer for Stormy
Daniels they negotiated a non-disclosure
agreement for a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars it's absolutely which I
mean again Michael Cohen's gonna say
here that it's [__]
um but that's a little bit of the of the
banter that that Costello gave which you
know it's always a kernel of Truth with
these [__] Texas Paul because
just because just because Michael Cohen
is caught on recordings like look we
gotta find a way to do this where it
looks like I came up with this on my own
wink like just be I mean Michael Cohen
has admitted that he committed crime
here Michael Cohen is not saying I
wasn't the one that committed crime it's
Trump he's like no that [__] we
were committing crime together and we
knew we were committing crime when we
were doing that was the whole point was
to make sure that no one knew and we had
we had to commit crime to cover it all
up I just don't understand how people
don't see this well you know everybody
nobody believes you know will believe
this lie but everybody will believe a
confession and that's exactly what Cohen
offered was a complete confession and
and
it's even better than that did you he
went on a rant Costello went on a rant
about well well the uh Grandeur who just
wasn't even interested in what I had to
say they didn't ask any questions they
didn't yeah you [__] your client is
what you did I mean they they people are
not stupid they've heard like like Gabe
said they have heard the testimony
you're the last freaking guy to talk to
them they know everything that's going
on and your [__] stunk to high
heaven and they knew it you what you did
is you entered that grand jury and you
made your boss a liar before the first
damn bit of testimony is offered I mean
it's just it's freaking hilarious how
bad these guys are and also the I want
to end one thing so in that in that kind
of rant that uh that costella had
yesterday he talked about there's 300
300 emails or something like that
something some number three thousand or
I forget the actual moment
but he goes look there are these 300 and
some odd emails that I have that they
weren't even interested in they wanted
to see like a few right and he's like
I'm gonna and then I and he thought that
was a good point to make like they but
they didn't want to see these because
they have nothing to do but then he also
added he was like oh I'll be releasing
them and I'm like great release him but
don't don't just talk about how you have
this evidence and they weren't willing
to accept it this is again this is a
talking point of the right they'll say
nobody on the left wanted to hear this
because it was a George Soros funded
operation but I have all this evidence
the grand jury it has nothing to do with
break no one if no one wanted to see it
feel free put it online put it oh just
open source that [__] give it to Elon
he'll give it to Matt taibi yeah and
they'll put it on a Twitter files or
something it's like this guy never
watched freaking Judge Judy man you ever
seen anybody tried to pull that [__]
with Judge Judy well I got up in the
morning and I had toast for breakfast
and she shut the hell up and where are
you on the damn corner at 9 32 p.m
that's what I want to know right I don't
give a [__] about your breakfast or your
car ride or your argument with your
girlfriend were you freaking there at 9
30 too
now we all know we're we're done where
Texas Paul gets his fire here he gets it
from Judge Judy
um speaking speaking of adjudication the
Judiciary Committee in the house
yesterday
politically politically threatened uh
Alvin Bragg and the D.A
um here is here's the uh chairman of the
weaponization committee and here's him
weaponizing the federal government
against the D.A which he has no right to
do
um but let's let's listen to Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan's [__] and
then what changed president Trump
announces he's running for president and
Shazam now they're gonna now they're
gonna Shazam that we're gonna some
bookkeeping air from seven years ago as
misdemeanor is now now what they're
going after so it makes absolutely no
sense but you don't know what the
charges are it gets from the foreign
we don't think we don't think president
Trump broke the law at all oh boy again
the plot line already slips away from
these morons when I don't know you just
start asking a question and they're like
whoa Jim Jordan's like whoa whoa whoa
whoa we're cheers
like Jim Jordan dude a mile a minute the
guy whenever you ask him a question that
he knows that he's wrong right you you
saw the video and when he was asked how
many times he spoke to Jim Jordan on
January 6 he's like well I gotta I gotta
I gotta look at my account I got a phone
I got a phone and that phone and that
phone has email on it and the email but
but it also has text messaging and see I
got an app called signal but I but I was
I see Trader the treason I was doing it
was not on that it was on the phone but
I have another phone it just it doesn't
make any [__] sense and look at
little Jimmy Jordan there I mean well I
don't think a crime is committed well
you just said well there was a
bookkeeping error well you know what
booking The Heirs can be [__] crimes
and then you just said well it's a
misdemeanor which is a damn lie because
it's actually a felony but you know I
mean it's just but there's no crime what
the hell was a mystery even in your own
out of your own damn mouth you said it
was a misdemeanor which you're wrong
about but it you know it's a felony but
even you said it was a freaking crime
two and a half seconds ago you dickwad I
have no idea no idea what the actual
crimes or charges are right like
everyone assumes that it's all just this
payment but we don't know what extra
like there has to if if Alvin Bragg
again if Alvin Bragg came into office
and said look there's no case here we
tried this before there's no case and
then now says actually we do have a case
we don't know why the only people again
that know this the full like the full
context are going to be the jury right
the the people yeah the D.A and the
grand jury right the people who have the
evidence who have the full case I want
to remind the audience that there there
is it is possible now I mean you can say
anything's possible it is possible that
they unearth a new piece of evidence
that shows that there was a crime
committed after the hush money payment
after he paid Michael Cohen after
Michael Cohen went to [__] prison
folks there was a criminal trial going
on in the state of New York against Alan
weiselberg and the Trump organization
and they were trying to shore up
anything they could and if you don't
think that Donald Trump has the
capability or or the wherewithal or the
[__] Mo to commit to commit
obstruction and witness tampering in
that case to make sure the stormy Daniel
case did not become a part of the Trump
organization case you were out of your
mind that you don't know that that's a
possibility um I want to show you
another a couple other tapes if you've
got a few minutes here
um here is um Roger Stone he wants us to
pray for Trump this is incredible watch
this
is now vitally important that every
American uh pray uh for the uh for the
safety of President Trump and his family
uh and his enormous courage uh in this
moment as I said earlier I spoke to him
Sunday morning he called me we was he in
church on the phone oh yeah I guess so
he was in an excellent mood uh he is a
man completely without fear because he
puts his faith in the Lord why does why
do people need to pray for him uh for
his safety if he's a man uh of no fear
and he puts his faith in the Lord and
the Lord will protect him why why do
they do these stupid things especially
because here's the thing the funny thing
is even on this Twitter space we're on
yesterday he people were admitting
they're like look
Donald people on the right were like
Donald Trump is not a religious man
right we know he's not religious right
so
two Corinthians
it says it says it in the Bible in two
Corinthians that Trump is not religious
yeah yeah there it says
it's his favorite book it's his favorite
book so it says it right exactly it has
to but uh but even yesterday these
people that were on this space were like
oh yeah they uh they admitted to the
fact that Trump was not religious like
Trump isn't even a religious man right
because they were trying to make the
argument about what what is really the
crime that's done here right and they
were bringing up morality and religious
stuff and I was like religious people
don't give a [__] they already they
already compromised on their moral
values right
they're gonna vote for him in a prime
what you're saying right there Gabe 100
I was I was warning people about don't
believe this Tuesday [__] from Trump
and the other thing I was warning people
about is do not underestimate how easily
these Maga [__] are gonna switch from
Trump to DeSantis the minute Trump is in
in hot water the minute that he he gets
convicted and it rolls over you know
Tony They're Gonna Roll this up they're
going to roll this up and there will be
more crimes coming out of this
the minute Trump's in trouble they are
going to jump off the Trump train and
they know well we love Trump but
DeSantis doesn't have the baggage you
know I mean I'll tell you I disagree
there and here's why is because I think
I think Gabe's right I don't think the
Christian right or the right gives a
[__] if he's indicted I don't care if
he's going to criminal trial they don't
care if he's convicted they don't give a
[__] what crime it is trust me in these
spaces all they have to say is it's all
fake it's all phony it's all political
and I don't believe a damn word of it
and I never will even if they convict
him I'm telling you they're delusional
and and I'm telling you that that the
greatest wedge that we can draw to win
2024 is between tiny d desantos uh
putting meatball as I call him here and
and the Cheeto dust q and honor
absolutely absolutely
a lot of them are going to switch really
easily I mean you watch like but but
you're absolutely right like when we
looked at the the fox numbers after they
got busted lying you know 13 of fox
viewers switched over and started
believing oh well yeah the election
wasn't stolen they stopped believing the
big lie I mean they're they're there's
going to be movement in there and we
definitely need to be drawing that
driving that wedge in there but yeah
[__] ton of them as soon as Trump starts
to drop in the polls they're going to
jump on the DeSantis train our job is to
make sure we're standing there with
plywood knocking enough of them [__]
out just out of the process you know I
mean if you can get if you can get five
percent of those [__] to stay home
right we win every election because we
talked about this that
um Democrats Democrats in their
messaging need to engage in in
suppression I mean they're they're
always accusing us of voter suppression
so yeah you damn right let's do it and
and really honestly we should
gerrymander the [__] at least threaten
it uh in these State houses uh in these
blue States like like we can again we've
said it before I've said it uh time and
time again the the day that Mark
Alliance has to sue democrats for
gerrymandering is the day Republicans
will lay down their sword for
gerrymandering that is the day
um speaking of [__] boxes here's Kevin
McCarthy taking a question this morning
he he there man when I say the plot line
is leaving them they I mean they're all
over the map with this [__] they do not
have a coordinated message folks they
they do not have a coordinated message
they do not have talking points years
ago back in the good old days with Rush
Limbaugh and Fox News before Trump
became along and became the integral
part in the Machinery of uh the RNC and
the Republican party before it became to
all just it went to [__] and Chaos they
actually had talking points that they
would release every [__] day and
these Republicans would have those
talking points before they got on camera
before they got into a mic on a
microphone that day and those are the
talking points they talked about they
were on point they were on message they
were on script they are way off script
they have no idea what to do Tony that's
why I'm all over John Edwards man that's
why I'm all over John Edwards because
that was going to be their talking point
that we defended John Edwards and now
we're Hypocrites because we want to
convict Trump for the same thing John
Edwards did and got off got off doing
I've been all over that [__] and I'm
telling you that the and it's really
I've had several of them try to come in
with that talk bust that talking point
out and and they can't do it because
we're ahead of the ball we are leading
the way on that he's as just as much of
a [__] bag as John Edwards was well
here's here's Kevin McCarthy and he and
I'm not going to play the whole tape but
listen to where he goes with the pot
line here how it's slipping away from
him
yesterday
indictment charges
interesting someone someone briefed me
down
um
the use of money a situation like this
before yeah and you probably covered
this sure remember when the DNC and
Hillary Clinton paid the law firm a
million dollars but it and and said that
it was for something else and we found
out later it wasn't it was all about the
Russia collusion it wasn't for legal
part and so they went through
and they got investigated oh my god did
you hear that holy [__] they did
something that was suspicious and guess
what happened Texas Paul guess what
happened Gabe they were investigated
what the f what the [__] don't they
understand about this they're saying it
they St he's trying to make a point and
it slips right through his fingers he
runs right into the point yes Hillary
and the DNC was investigating for that
yeah and they didn't find any crime they
found they found things that they
shouldn't have done and they fined them
for it they were investigated and they
were punished what in the [__] don't you
understand about Justice and
investigation almost anyone's saying is
Donald Trump is being investigated here
just wait it out and see what happens
you [__] manga idiots but that's what
they do right that's that's how they
that that that that the John the John
Edwards John Kerry like all this stuff
that's brought up you know Hillary
Clinton yesterday
Paula Jones it's like look
if you're one either you're trying to
argue and admit that this is actually
something they did or two you're trying
to play both sides and say well you can
investigate them but don't investigate
us right we want to investigate the
investigators who are investigating us
about this crime that we did just
play it out just for the just the same
way that it's like dude you don't know
what is going on and what the actual
crimes that he's being charged with
right you you have the idea which is
like the payment that's that's the thing
that wedged this open but you don't know
what else comes with it and the same
thing here is like you want to bring up
Hillary Clinton they were investigated
they were fined like if you really want
this to be a fair kind of situation then
you would also allow this to happen but
unfortunately that's not how they work
well here's Jimmy Kimmel's take I want
to I want this to be the last video it's
it's about a minute long let's listen to
this we'll talk any other side and uh
because we're running out of time we
have to jet out of here but listen to
this Jimmy Kimmel his take last night
the truth is
there's no good reason for Trump to be
in any of this trouble if Casa no brain
had just paid Stormy Daniels the 130 000
himself out of his Pizza Hut money or
whatever he wouldn't be in this
situation he wouldn't have an issue in
New York so many of his legal problems
are based on him being an idiot if
president Karen hadn't picked up the
phone and called around Georgia asking
to speak to its manager to find 11 000
votes he wouldn't have an issue in
Georgia if he just tweeted the words
calm down go home four hours earlier
like everyone including his daughters
told him to he wouldn't have an issue on
January 6th and if the Great White Hope
Chest hadn't boxed up his love letters
from the Saudis and Kim Jong-un he then
squirreled them out of the White House
and into the rec room at calphalago he
wouldn't have an issue with the FBI in
every case the reason he's in trouble is
because he is the dumbest criminal in
the world
on himself
he's Al Capone head is what he is
alka bonehead
is Pizza Hut money I mean I I could not
play Jimmy's uh thing there and really
again the reason why they're losing the
plot line is exactly what Jimmy Kimmel
is saying the reason why is because
Donald Trump is the cause of all this he
is the cause of all of it he's the
reason why we know what we know about
the documents he's the reason why
January 6 happened and we know he stood
on [__] stage and they call he he he
continued to message his supporters
weeks prior it's going to be wild come
protect me come make me the president
come make me the king he's doing it now
on true social about this [__] man
NDA he he talks about the two perfect
phone calls in Georgia he talks about
him it's because he's a [__] idiot
and they are relying on him to be their
[__] leader that is why it seems so
[__] crazy and why we are at the
intersection of Wrestlemania and real
life and we have been here for a while
we're gonna be here for a while folks so
don't forget to subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast if you're on the
YouTube channel right now hit subscribe
it's [__] free why not it's [__]
free and if you aren't listening to show
what the hell's wrong with you uh go
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
POD at the Tony Michaels and that I am
Gabe Sanchez we'll be in the at Twitter
space later if you're on Twitter
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify and Google
also if you still have a Facebook
account if you're on Facebook follow us
at the Tony Michaels and check us out on
the up wires YouTube channel go to the
up bar.com follow the YouTube channel
and over on Twitch you can actually give
us Jeff bezos's money that's right you
can give us a Billionaire's money here
at the Tony Michaels podcast it doesn't
cost you a nickel here's how it works
Texas Paul they go and they they link
their Amazon Prime account to their
Twitch account and they get one free
subscription and they give that
description to subscription to whoever
they want and I get a little bit of Jeff
bezos's money so if you want me to have
Amazon's money yeah just go link them
and give the subscription to me I'll get
a few dollars every month you have to
renew it every month so if you have it
out there if you have it out there and
you have it linked you got to go into
twitch every month and give your
subscription to who you want to give it
to so don't forget to do that as well
Texas phone give us your your plug here
we got your link down in the description
below but give us your plug here
yeah we're doing it every every Sunday
we've got it we've got a great Newsweek
wrap up Sunday coffee with Texas Paul
9pm or 9 A.M Central come join us you
can get the link directly uh from
realtexaspaul.com it'll take you right
to the YouTube page and you're in like
Flynn baby hey nice hat by the way Gabe
do you have anything on your patreon
going on uh yeah so uh I've got a Tony
well Tony saw it last night there's a
little bait I'm getting back into the
sketches and the FaceTime calls and
there's a FaceTime call between me and
Rudy Giuliani he sings me uh
Little Teapot uh song uh so that'll be
coming out later today uh but yeah I've
gotta I'm working on a couple more what
was that episode's uh extended versions
as well
um more to see so please become a member
subscribe I love you so go to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez and while
you're on patreon's website or the app
don't forget to visit my page
patreon.com the Tony Michaels just type
in the Tony Michaels and you can find my
page on there as well I got some new
clips coming out I'll be releasing um
we're gonna the piper Jess Piper's
interview yesterday I think I'm gonna
put the link up there for the patreon
members first so you can go re-watch I'm
gonna post that video on YouTube alone
and then you'll be able to watch it and
then there should be a clip coming of
that as well so in the coming days so go
check out patreon.com D Tony Michaels
and check out Gabe's page while you're
there for that Giuliani uh I'm a Little
Teapot video that phone call you got
from Rudy Rudy kaluti Grandpa farty make
shardy Rudy Giuliani so go to
patreon.com and search me and Gabe and
you can find us there and everybody it's
I'm I'm imagining that this afternoon
will be a big news day but tomorrow it's
going to be even bigger so don't don't
miss this show tomorrow be here same
time same place Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
IL born head ass Beacon